the Joe Rogan experience how do you guys
write songs do you write them and you
come to each other independently do you
do you collaborate like only in studio
do you write them in studio weave for
the most part always just made them up
just improvise them like in the move in
the moment mmm and then said you liked
it let's try to put this down again just
sort of gravitate towards what we like
and then just start building on it and
all the stuff that doesn't work push it
away and just keep going forward
do you have disagreements on what works
or doesn't work when you're really no
not usually it's always been like that
ever since we were 16 and 17 Wow yeah
I've never really I don't think the
older I get the more I realize how
special that is you know I always took
it for granted I mean I remember when we
were trying to audition bass players we
had this one guy try to come and play
with us and I just remember it just
[ __ ] everything up it's like we
couldn't even play it didn't even sound
like us why it just didn't work and then
wasn't when this other person left all
of a sudden it sounded like a big band
again huh it was weird I mean we learned
to play together i I never even played
I've never I mean I never played drums
with anybody aside from it Dan and that
me even playing drums in the band it's
like because it was a kind of an
accident
I only had a drum set because I wanted
to be a guitar player and I wanted
people to come to my house and play the
drums with before I had a driver's
license I got a job washing dishes and
bought this truck I bought everything
you need for a band and like my friends
would come over and they were all pretty
much better at guitar than me but Dan
came over and he was like the best
guitar player of all my friends and I
was like [ __ ] what do I do bass or drums
I was like well you can't just jam
guitar bass i sat down at the drums and
that's what we did in high school so we
learned to play together man so because
of that there's like there is like a
psychic kind of connection mm-hmm you
know I mean we play now on stage with a
couple other guys and it's it's it's
good it's easy it's fun
but there is something when the two of
us start playing where it is we can like
work in between beats you know it's
pretty liquid our goal has never been
like to be this tight kind of rigid like
don't you know I mean like tightness
isn't something it's more about like the
energy the feeling it's hard to describe
but it's like yeah we never worried
about if we got it perfect we always it
was always does that this is the one
that feels best hmm always what more
important do you write the lyrics down
do you write the music down once I made
it I'll write lyrics sometimes I'll
improvise words a lot of the new record
was a lot of like improvising syllables
and words really yeah yeah yeah there's
just no rules absolutely no rules but a
lot of times I'll I'll be trying to UM
be singing a melody while I'm doing
chord changes but I can see pat you know
that's the thing that we've always done
we've always been able to see each other
when we play and record so you know and
go with his movements and follow him
that way so you guys just know each
other so well you well you know we
hadn't we hadn't been in this together
for five and a half years and we didn't
do any pre-production or anything in the
very first idea that we had made the
record yeah Wow
I mean it's just it's a crazy man crazy
connection yeah man that's so unusual it
really is the older I get the more I
realize that well you guys have been
together for so long and this the thing
with bands is like this is my first band
it's at first I was never in another
like the Black Keys like the first real
band does it yes first real band I've
been in it's so great so I didn't know
any different I thought I danced felt
like this you know what I mean that's
the saddest thing when you see bands in
the lead guitar players mad singer and
you know Oh guys come on really
yeah it's always over some dumb [ __ ]
it's usually like someone's wife is yep
[ __ ] mean and yeah wasn't that what
the date the David Lee Roth hey we've
been through that [ __ ] man
we've been through it and poof it's like
yeah it's hard it's hard you know I mean
like oh yeah if I could go back in time
and give like our 22 year old selves one
piece of advice it would be like don't
prob don't tour with your girlfriend
until you like have a kid and they come
out for a couple shows this avoid that
[ __ ] and also probably like don't don't
really have a girlfriend till you're
like in your late 20s probably mmm
what's the problem with touring with the
girlfriend dude it's just a codependent
[ __ ] like me that it was just
really hard I had to get through I've
grown up a lot
you know I mean but yeah it's just hard
it's like the hard part is that I'm up
for the work and Dan's up for the work
and when we're on tour like going
through I've got through a period to
tell her I get phone calls be like what
the [ __ ] are you doing [ __ ] you
know or no like I miss you like that
guilt sir it's just like I'm like
literally in the back of a Ford account
of angel like with like a torn-up copy
of TV Guide reading it for the fifth
time because there are many money no
cell phone or like with a Nokia phone
like I get in the guilt trip and stuff
it's like too real to even talk about
our first tour of number Dan having to
stop with the PayPal Wow
they have you at the pay phone in our
like whoever didn't like my brother Mike
was with us I think a man like sucks to
be Dan and then like literally like an
hour later I really I got I have to get
to pay for myself no masses been but you
have to go through that you have to
learn to appreciate a good relationship
you got to go through those where the
[ __ ] are you really yeah but I mean
that's the thing it's like it's well I
guess what does it kill you makes you
stronger although I read somewhere that
that's not actually true so I'm shaky
[ __ ] your body up it was I'm pretty
here just takes two years off your life
maybe it didn't kill you yeah took a
decade off your longevity you know
that's why that's why it we're able to
get to the spot where here we are 2019
and we're I don't think we're insane
people we're pretty close to the same
people we were when we were in our
twenties still wearing some of the same
t-shirts I'm not because there's way too
small for me
but yeah you know I think that there's
there's a time like maybe 2012 our [ __ ]
was really blowing up I mean we could do
no wrong and uh there was a there's
there's there's the alternate universe
for sure where we sure did to complete
tickets yeah we died multiple times at
the Chateau it's like yeah and this it
is in this version of reality dan and
Patrick don't play the Spike TV Video
Game Awards they overdose at the Chateau
Marmont yeah yeah do you mean you have
to appreciate though that you guys have
gone through quite the gauntlet and it's
pretty amazing I think that the best
thing that ever happened to us is uh
that we didn't experience six success to
our sixth album and when and what it is
because if we would have got that we're
23 we would have never been able to sit
down and realize what what [ __ ] was
going on yeah yeah everything everything
about us has been just for ridiculous
synchronistic yeah but it's also that
kind of luck and timing and rightfully
that's where the simulation comes in bro
I think that's just where the that's I
think that's just we're like the
uniqueness and the crazy thing that's
the crazy thing about life is that it is
certain things are rare it shouldn't be
that crazy that a register like Danone
eyes is so rare but it is
[Applause]